why do I think a lot of you don't do
[ __ ] because you are people's opinions
of you you got your perspective as you
guys know it's 2017 so much of my thesis
--is and ideas are available on YouTube
but the fact that we're here together I
think what I've learned in this
environment is if you go selfish and
that ask a very specific question that
you think that I might be be able to
bring some value to a lot of times 80%
of the room has also got something
similar that's going through their mind
so if I can encourage the table that's
got the green thing right now if that
you want to ask the first question and
then on the left side here if you guys
want to line up behind this mic to ask
your questions I think you know if you
want to go high level you know to me the
world is broken up into branding and
sales so people in here are thinking
about converting and selling something
in in what I would call below the funnel
kind of like just transactional sales
and then I think for a lot of you that
watch what I do I spend a lot more time
selling at the brand level there's no
real ask there's no right hook it's
about to be very frank with you guilting
people into opportunities and building
brand like nobody here especially groups
like this you know especially knowing a
lot about what I know about at this
point like I think a lot of the
conversation should be how brand lowers
cost of acquisition but then a lot of
your business owners like I've built two
businesses a lot of culture HR human
retention hunting farming so you know
anything as basic as like how do I make
snapchats sell me [ __ ] like I'm thrilled
to answer anything you can go anywhere
you know you want to talk about the
[ __ ] call yesterday in the Jets game
I'm thrilled to answer anything
I don't know like please don't even get
me started
so I'm willing to answer anything and
everything well I'd love to help so
what's your name I mean Carlos Carlos
okay I really appreciate that I love you
Gary
you know Jack Deveny thank you sir yeah
I haven't full delicious no problem the
u.s. red said but he also wanted me to
change yes you know social media culture
yes I have a name I have a certainty
with understandable okay but I haven't
invested in the steps that sometimes you
play out so if you're to give me an
advice I have a reputation
yes I have a following yes but I haven't
tapped into what it is that is in
facebook is well it's accommodation
what's what's your gut before I answer
it I'm thrilled to what's your intuition
on what you haven't really done enough
of you somewhere I will be I'm sorry I
won't be on camera before and after
experience
yes then I'm all kind of there I didn't
catch the food I mean I guess there are
the elements back to be place a
structure you know I'm gonna spend the
time with it but I mean I can do a video
selfie that you have talked to me the
vision that they they launched it and
how much Metallica
yes not just one
that woman might say that understood
with you know but I'm giving you you are
like that one of the gods off social
media month even because you could to
the [ __ ] you tell her this and I'm
gonna gonna have to please one here to
just tell their actually that's like
different like bad boys so what no I'm
just saying if I have the gift of being
a destructor yes that came across my
before and after that experience every
single person yes trustee distance I see
that don't worry you'll never frag as
much as me so we'll be fine more the war
yes the seventeen and that one might
walk back home my beautiful wife here
I'm gonna say okay over the do with you
you know there's not monetizing no I
totally get it
you know your very big eyes on the most
humble guy I'm not trying to say that
looks right yeah I'll give it to you
Carlos I think what's very obvious look
for all of us there's the message and
distribution right you know whatever
your version of what Carlos is feeling
about his skill set we all have it
I think the biggest thing that I could
tell you you know a lot of times when I
speak I'm always thinking about like
what can I say that changes the outcome
of the room right the reason I love
doing QA is I think that most speakers
are too self-serving and I think when
you speak you need to have empathy and
you need to deliver right so when I hear
that question what I'm excited about is
right off the bat we're five seconds in
and you asked a question Carlos that I
think is probably the most important
thing I could leave here with which is
if I could get even one person to
execute on what I'm about to say that
person's impact and their to your point
I think much more about my legacy than
my currency this is not necessarily when
you've got something to say you know you
pretty quickly get away from worrying
about the money you get into [ __ ] I want
to get this all out before I'm gone
right so for me the biggest thing that I
want to say is that the second everybody
in this room realizes that there are
meat
company first and then whatever they do
for a living
second everything will change when I
hear what you say I said well that guy
needs a full-time editor-in-chief around
brand Carlos you should film everything
you should turn all that filming into
audio all that audio should be turning
to a written word I think of myself at
this point as a triple threat as a media
company I'm putting out tons of video
tons of audio and tons of written word
and some of you like how many people
here to listen to my podcast right I
mean that's crazy that's most of this
room and like two years ago I wasn't
even thinking about audio right but as
we've gotten busier audios grown because
it's passive you can listen to me while
you're doing other [ __ ] if you want to
watch my video you got to watch the
video right so everything keeps changing
Carlos I think the first thing that you
need to think about is you sort need to
thinking about yourself as ESPN and HBO
and CNBC and the New York Times the
quicker all of you think of yourself as
that everything changes I literally
think that I garyvee don't compete with
Richard Branson or with you know Mark
Cuban I think that Gary Vee competes
with Business Insider and Forbes and and
you know the Wall Street Journal and
Complex magazine like I I don't think
about competing with humans
I spend zero time even debating that and
so I think of myself Carlos is a media
company and so it's the difference
between you know what I think a lot of
people do in our world they turn into
infomercials versus 20/20 if you make
content on Facebook and LinkedIn and
your email and everything you do if you
think of yourself as ABC News if you
think about yourself as fox or CNN
instead of an infomercial [ __ ] changes
and so I highly recommend that all of
you and especially you if you're sitting
on something like that what's you know
everybody's thinking like an advertiser
not as a media company and I think for a
lot of me it seems like you know
watching your kind of behavior that's
why I feel a little bit different
I'm not putting out content like an
advertiser with a short-term goal I'm
putting out content like a me
a company with a long-term goal which
creates short-term opportunity it's a
very very subtle but disproportionate
reason and and the luckier you are if
you're this legendary as people are
whispering to me well then that means
you're sitting with something which
means you should be recording all of it
all of it that's right and the way to
think about it is some of you don't have
the dollars to hire somebody yet and
neither did I for the first eight years
the whole d-roc thing and all this you
know I love whatever was like easy for
you Gary
you have d-roc now and then I'm like
dick I didn't have anybody for eight
years and I built up to it and then I
had somebody so like if you've got to do
it in selfie form good and if like for
me I can't write I've ghostwriter for my
books I have a ghostwriter for my
LinkedIn a medium right now I can't
write it's not how I communicate but I
can do video some of you are scared of
video and get awkward you're more
introverted so then write use the medium
that helps you best communicate and then
build around it so maybe you write and
maybe somebody makes video content
transcribing your written words into
audio like you just got a bat against
what you're good at but you've got to
fill out all the other ways because
people can consuming content in all
different forms I don't want to
discriminate on how you guys want to
consume me you want to listen while
you're brushing your teeth
mazelTov you want to read on the way to
the trip to your you know office great
you want to watch a video because you
need a boost and you need to see the
insanity great I just don't want to be
the judge and too many people are making
content that they would consume not I'd
only think about you not me you need to
put out everything and then if you're
you know the quicker you take money and
this is for a lot of you in the room
because there's a lot of business people
here the quicker you take your money and
put it into another person that helps
you make more content versus buying some
[ __ ] for yourself
the quicker you build an actual [ __ ]
business
I think it's gonna be on in a minute I
hope let's see try again not yet can we
let's see if we how about now nope how
about now you can but I want to make
sure they get the audio okay we'll try
to fix that while we give you the
cashbox hello there we go
right in the nick of time what's your
name in yeah pleasure thanks for the
excellent watch all yours so I wouldn't
get more about Gary Vaynerchuk see okay
we're talking a lot just now the nesting
your money back into getting more people
yes and so I'm fascinated about what you
believe as far as like having a Claude
silver and a heart officer and thing
along those lines and I really
appreciate you go great tactical please
with the people in this room you know we
start at a very you know we have much
smaller companies most of us than
getting if we're building up what are
some do's and don'ts as we're trying to
player so playing with me here so you
can help everybody so first of all you
have to know one thing I always do is
first try to figure out what I'm trying
to accomplish so for me Carlos back to
you recalling you I wanted to set out to
not only buy the New York Jets but have
a legacy in the entrepreneur space that
was the perfect balance between making a
lot of money and being successful and
doing it in the best human way I wanted
to be the nicest most successful person
I don't need to make the most money I
just needed to do it in the best way
help other people along the way help my
people along the way there's a lot of
weird things so for example you have to
know yourself if you're in it for the
money there's nothing wrong with that
you just need to know that so for
example because I knew I wanted legacy
even as a 23 year old when I started
running my dad's business and you know
the first year I ran the business I went
from three to ten million that's like
[ __ ] like that changes everything right
even the way I fired people like the
severance says I give are so ridiculous
like my dad this is just the truth I
hate to call my dad out he would have
somebody work for him for seven years
fired them and not give him anything
very Russian I had people work for me
for a month and I've given him
months severance you know like so that
it's not because I'm a better person
than my dad it's because I knew what
I've set out to do so the first thing I
tell all of you is figure out what
you're setting out to do both from a
financial standpoint and a reputation
and legacy standpoint because once you
understand what you're trying to achieve
how much you want to make what do you
want to do with your money what's your
work-life balance what where do you sit
on the Pantheon is it just about the
dollars is it not like are you leaving
it to your kids are you selling it to go
fish
what are you doing because this is the
biggest reason my man Daniel that a lot
of people aren't doing the things that
they need to do cuz they're just kind of
it's just about the money there's no rat
race of like this year I want to make a
hundred thousand next year for just like
it's it's you know you want to pay your
debt off from school or you know buy
your mom a house it's very very narrow
and I started right from 15 thinking
about who I was gonna be at 90 and
working backwards so that's number one
but the reason I started macro to go
very tactical on you is because I know I
don't want to sell vaynermedia I don't
have to maximize the ebody of the
business I don't need to maximize the
profit of vaynermedia year and year out
because I'm not selling it so I never
have the worry that somebody's gonna
swoop in and offer me money for my
business and then when I look at the
bottom line I want to make sure the
profits real good for that sale I'd have
to spend a year or two setting it up for
the sale high just to get everybody
grounded have decided to build the best
marketing machine I was called the comms
and marketing Deathstar except with the
little without the little flaw that Luke
[ __ ] shot and whether you know I
don't want to go away so like I want to
build the greatest marketing machine of
all time and in my 50 60s and 70s
I want to buy very big businesses like
Reebok or Yahoo chocolate drink or
Gymboree like big businesses that you
know and I want to buy them and run them
through the Machine buy them for four
hundred eight million sell them for 3.7
billion right like that's why I'm doing
it so again I'm giving a long-winded
answer because we got some time together
now you know why I have a cheap heart
officer and why claude's the most
important person I spend all my time on
HR either thinking about it or spending
time with my employees cuz it's
family if I was gonna sell it in four
years I wouldn't I wouldn't spend all my
time with mine you know a lot of times
could've like everything you're the best
chief you know somebody like who really
knows my [ __ ] I've hired a chief uh-huh
heart officer and I'm gonna spend all my
time on HR and I'm like well what are
you doing they're like oh I'm gonna
build this up and sell it in two years
I'm like you shouldn't spend any time
with anybody you need to maximize
profits and the [ __ ] cost and like you
probably want people quitting to lower
like like you want attrition so you know
what I've done my whole career is I
realize people are the variable of
success there's way too much ego in
business like humility and empathy are
your secret powers everybody wants to be
the man be the guy be the gal be the one
be the girl like everybody wants to be
that person and I just basically every
morning wake up and know that I work for
everybody and nobody works for me as the
CEO how many people here struggle with
expecting people that work for them to
work as hard as them I mean just
ludicrous
ludicrous audacity at best and straight
[ __ ] [ __ ] ish miss at worse right
so like I think about this [ __ ] every
day like you know for me it's people
centric you know like people always like
I can't get my cashiers to like [ __ ]
work because they're only 12 bucks an
hour like no it's because you've never
said hello to them dick face right so
like I'm very people centric I think
there's enormous ROI either in the short
term or the long term some of the people
that work for me I risk may go on to win
an Academy Award as a filmmaker right
like I'd much rather have her like me
than not like me you know everybody's
playing short term I don't live as if it
tomorrow I'm gonna die and I'm stunned
by how many people do it's all short
term ROI every decision is short term
ROI and I think that's a huge decision
so internally I spend a lot of time and
money my HR department 2bic my time that
I spend with employees too much this is
what I hear from all my business
associates who then spend all their time
asking me how I do it
so you know I'm a big culture guy I
agree with you like my intuition is that
94% of this room is not culture oriented
their money oriented it's just the way
it is it's not because of this room it's
because of every room of every business
conversation in the world and and in
that arbitrage
I'm gonna build a huge legacy and buy
the New York Jets and so I think that
everybody here should take a step back
and realize what actually drives their
business I think I'm looking around
there's a lot of youngsters here which
means a lot of them have never been
including you probably held are you yeah
you've never been punched in the mouth
right meaning you know I worry about
people under 30 who've been basically
navigating their careers during good
economic times basically since 2009
we've been growing right so for a couple
of us a little older here we remember
the morning of Bear Stearns we remember
the 2000 you know April 2000 economic
bubble burst like until we get punched
in the mouth you're not a real player so
right now we have a lot of people under
30 who need to realize when you get
punched in the mouth
it's those employees and humans that are
the ones that allow you to survive it
not the other way around and so there's
a lot of naivete there's a lot of
inexperience and there's a lot of
short-term financial decision-making so
I interview all my senior people I spend
an enormous amount of time telling them
they'll get fired if they don't play
nice with the other boys and girls the
number one flaw that a lot of people
have in their company right now is their
biggest moneymaker is also their biggest
[ __ ] and they're letting them get
away with it because of the money making
that's creating massive cancer
internally within organizations right
now they should all be the best that the
reason I'm so good it's one of the
biggest reasons I still be Gary Vee is
because I want to be the best that
social media so that I'm never at the
mercy of any of my employees I've never
had an employee that's had any
significant leverage against me ever in
the history of my career and you know
which is I've never even had a sales
team that's been bonused on sales like
I've just never put myself in a position
to be at the mercy of somebody and I
think a lot of people do that so if
something to think about
and then finally you have to know what
they care about one of my best people
that runs Facebook Ads still works for
me because I bought him st. Louis
Cardinals tickets cuz I knew he was a
st. Louis Cardinals fan and it meant so
much to him that he's passed up Facebook
and Google offering him 50 to $100,000 a
year more in salary because he feels
good about me so some people trade on
money which is great by the way I wish
every one of my employees traded on
money and be simple how much do you want
good I can do that how much you want I
can't do that how much you want I can do
that like that's easy the problem is a
lot of your employees work on work-life
balance a lot of your employees
completely trade on you just
acknowledging them means I mean I can't
wrap my head around what's actually
going on in the world like how are you
an owner and not saying hello date like
who the [ __ ] do you think you are so
that's how I feel that's really how I
feel I watch it I watch managers and
owners that's the reason so many people
struggle with going to management when
they were Indians it was fun to make fun
of the Chiefs but when you become a
chief it's hard right it's a whole
different game what got you to
management is nothing what gets you to
the next place you're the ultimate
manager if you on your [ __ ] you only
work for everybody else the customer
your employees for me it's my employees
first then the customer then I can even
begin to think about what the [ __ ] in
it for me
and I've just watched 95% of the
business and I interact with start with
them then the customer then they're in
place I think that most of the people
are broken and I think if you have if
you are if you're honest
no [ __ ] right if it just went
through your mind like [ __ ] I am me then
customer than my employees you will lose
and I can tell you that's the majority
of businesses so anything else I can add
cuz I know you want to detail I went
macro I'd like to close some gap
actively like what is like one thing
that I should do or not do how many
employees do you have if any no none
nine you should talk to them and ask
them what they give a [ __ ] about when's
the last time tell me the truth don't
lie in front these people
what's the last time when's the last
time you've literally sat down with all
nine of them for 45 minutes over
breakfast lunch or dinner and said what
are the biggest things that you're
interested in for me to do and the other
eight too and the other eight as well
that's it my man
I love and I first of all thank you for
your honesty and number listen you might
have you it seems like you're deep in my
content you've probably heard me
recently say I'm [ __ ] up too I think
this open-door policy is working it's
not working for [ __ ] so next year I'm
spending [ __ ] redoing my whole
schedule I've canceled I'm not speaking
at all next year I'm like doing like six
events compared to 40 just so I have the
more of the man-hours to now force every
one of my 750 people to see me for 15
minutes every six months so you have you
have eight and other employees you've
got a [ __ ] you should be done this
week and here's how it goes Daniel Karen
Rick Susan the [ __ ] do you want from me
what can I do for you you may find that
she wants to leave early on Fridays
because she's missing recitals and that
changes her whole life that she'll
dominate for you Monday through Friday
and a half just for those two hours or
maybe somebody doesn't like the way
you're talking to them and so the number
one thing I do tactically is not only do
I sit down with them for 15 minutes
I'll spend the first 11 minutes getting
them comfortable with telling me the
truth
and then I'll follow up with a text with
an emoji in it and then I'll watch what
they do on social media and then I pay
attention to who they're friends with
I'm like I'm a full time listener
everybody thinks I talk all the time all
I'm doing is listening the biggest
reason I talk so much is to get
reactions from you whether one-on-one
you in an audience like this or the
whole [ __ ] world when I
content I talked so much strategically
to get reactions so I can listen so I
can readjust you know it's fun when I
talk to anything that even remotely
touches martial arts because I didn't
realize this because I didn't know
anything about it like I'm all
reactionary I'm all that that's what I'm
a counter-puncher I want I'm doing
things to force you into a move so I can
then do the next move it's chess I just
do it with communication I even think
that my personality in hindsight has
developed into this caricature of Who I
am to create the natural reaction
because I'm able to judge people very
quickly based on how they react to me I
got it yep so here's what's interesting
about me that's a little different I
don't know if you guys have pay
attention I have not set out to monetize
my audience like the majority of people
which I'm empathetic I get it what makes
me a little tough to use as a proxy is
I've always made my money in a separate
business than my audience buying stuff
for me super easy to give everything
away for free when you're not counting
on any of the money right here's the
mistake everybody makes everybody thinks
you give away some lightweight [ __ ] and
you sell your best stuff so what
everybody does I think it's the other
way around I give away all my best [ __ ]
if I was selling my audience I would
give away all my best [ __ ] and then what
I would sell is access on the scalable
stuff because if you're giving away
[ __ ] or stuff that's just not that
strong
you're never gonna get them into the
interest graph to begin with the other
thing is way too many people think
they're sitting on something that means
something information is commoditized
people want to sell information I make
fun of all my friends who think they're
gonna make a $97 eBook
I'm like bro I'm like cool but do you
feel good about selling somebody 97
dollars worth of [ __ ] that you just
control copied from the internet so I
think you hold on to something that is
not scalable so I think access
is not scalable your time it's not
scalable I think the best model is to
sell something that is not scalable
that's hard for you as the individual to
scale but then you can maximize it right
like you know I mean the amount of money
people offer me to spend an hour with me
is just like like the emails I get are
so crazy I mean there's people that are
tickets I some guys send me a hundred
thousand dollars in my PayPal just like
Cynthia's like one hour
I couldn't take and I just gave it to
him for free but like what what it told
me was [ __ ] this is so right this is so
right so for all the people that are
trying to sell and do all these things
like you know like doing the right
things always the right thing so what do
you hold on to something that isn't
scalable what do you give away the best
[ __ ] you got which is
hours of videos tons of times video so
there's it's very difficult people go
back and see the notion of the curated
content as a packaged product is a fair
debate because time is valuable and so
for the people that are really stuck who
don't want to sell their time or don't
want to go with my model I think the one
thing that is a worthwhile debate is if
you curate all your stuff and one it's
kind of how I think of a book right like
yours for 13 bucks all over the last
year and a half in one place so you know
listen I'm not I'm not God you should
live here's my number one piece of
advice if you feel great about what you
sell sell whatever the [ __ ] you want
right but make sure you're not feeling
great because of the selfish needs for
the financial impact on your life make
sure you feel great because you've
looked at everything else that they
could spend their money on and will it
really work
[Applause]
yep I remember thank you brother
you got it we've got it right here
thank you so for all of you that don't
follow is hard you know just to give you
context I've been working on a book it's
probably why it's not out because it's
my true my true passion project it's
called perfectly parented how to raise
an entrepreneur it's basically a story
story of what my parents did for me you
know it's really cool with all the good
things that are happening with me in my
life I take zero credit I literally
think like at Vayner crushes it I feel
good
me but one of the reasons like I can sit
up here and like run the gamut of like
huge ego to huge humility is my parents
are the reason I'm sitting here my
parents in the fact that I was born in
an in a foreign country was raised as an
immigrant here in the United States and
really understand what's actually
happening here and how good it actually
is and I leave with optimism not
pessimism and so I appreciate that I
can't wait to write it I need to make
sure I write it yeah
done yes let me make this valuable for
everybody not just his selfish needs and
wants which was super fun and I'm
thrilled I can't wait to do it the
advice going further will really help a
lot of you please understand the time is
literally besides health the number one
asset so many of you asked for people to
do things that takes up their time for
your self-interest you need to go the
other way so much of what has made me
successful is creating less friction for
you guys I got to the podcast because
I'm like oh [ __ ] audios happening it's
better for you guys while you're running
while you're traveling let me put more
money into making a good podcast so I
can create less friction for you a lot
of people have these landing pages and
all this so you can get the data so you
can do your thing you're creating
friction anything that makes it better
for the other person when it comes to
time please keep that in mind that's why
the advice I gave to all these kids and
people that are starting podcasts they
want superstars on their show sure who
doesn't but the people that you want
have no time so I was like [ __ ] it start
a show that's like only a minute long or
two minutes like that you can get
somebody somebody might who's super busy
who just wants to get out there a little
bit we all do no matter where we are
right might be like well that sounds
good two minutes cool in so what do you
dame it the mindset minute how many have
you done how's it going good man you got
one listener ones better than zero bro
first two years I did Wine Library TV on
YouTube and people didn't even know what
YouTube was in 2006
you know nobody was watching 18 months
nobody and I'm losing money at Wine
Library because I'm spending all this
time trying to build this but I knew
right
too many people you know many
celebrities got [ __ ] by Instagram
because three years ago they didn't want
to jump into Instagram because other
people had a lot of followers and they
were a real celebrity and if they jumped
on and only had 10,000 followers that
would have made them look bad so what
they did was they never started now
they're not even a pseudo celebrity
because they never started too much ego
I'm thrilled to do everything because
what you're gonna make fun of me that my
podcast is ranked 10,000 and I should be
higher [ __ ] you you know what I mean too
many of you are not doing things because
you're worried about how it's gonna make
you look cuz you're late so you're not
starting which is always a bad idea
right it's a huge thing that's happening
I think this you know I'm always think
about the soundbite that may help you
I'm pumped right now because I have a
funny feeling two or three ever like
[ __ ] maybe I should you know you know I
get it I understand brand I understand
[ __ ] I'm supposed to be this and I have
less than all these but if you don't
start you don't get and by the way cream
always rises to the top if you're so
good right you'll be there right so many
people doing dumb [ __ ] you know many
people have 800,000 followers on
Instagram but they bought their
followers or their accounts smart people
know so cool you trick the 80% of idiots
but the 20% of people that know or the
1% that actually matter to know think
you're a loser in a short Carter right
be smart so number one self-awareness
again one of the things that I think has
really worked for me that I think I'm
putting pressure in this room on don't
[ __ ] yourself that's the quickest
way to lose and we do it so much because
we come up with stuff that we wish would
happen versus what we know will happen
as far as an exit strategy to me an
evergreen business is always great
unless you think you have a moment in
time right so view 47 acai bowl truck
food trucks you may want to anticipate
the
that food shred could change right but
if you you know but if you have a real
estate empire that doesn't go and you
know goes up and down but doesn't go
away so you need to first decide if your
business can go away outright right and
then finally just what are you gonna do
with the money I'm a big fan of peace a
lot of people sell their company with no
real intent for the money meaning they
just like the idea of it and they want
to buy some [ __ ] which is fine but like
with money being so cheap right now and
so little to put down on a mortgage like
what like what do you need so bad you
need to ask yourself so there's a matrix
of moment in time evergreen versus
selling it if you sell it look I mean I
should have probably sold a lot of
things I was so right about Facebook and
Amazon stock in the last seven years
opportunity cost I should have like
liquidated everything like if you know
what you want to do with the money and
you understand what you're getting
yourself into but I've seen so many
friends built build businesses for four
or five years build something nice fell
it because they see some other
opportunity they sell it that other
opportunity was nothing they knew
anything about they take the money they
put it into that that goes down they
could have been five years later people
don't like to work for some reason
sometimes right so like I never want to
sell anything and never have really sold
anything because I like working and
building and evergreening and legacy but
I'm also super empathetic and thinking a
lot of my friends have sold a lot of
companies that they were right buddy
media was right
Mike Lazaro made eight hundred million
dollars and it wouldn't have been worth
it wouldn't have been worth eight
million if he waited four years later so
you have to be smart if it's a moment in
time there's a lot of different
variables right bebo sold to AOL for 850
million dollars because that was the
social media you know platform scares of
the 2000s with MySpace and Facebook and
b-bone there's a high-five and so you
got to figure out how real your business
is and what you're gonna do with the
money but it's a very personal thing
right we're all going through our own
[ __ ] like so much you know and then
finally if you know you're gonna sell it
a lot of us entrepreneurs are not
fiscally great like I'm great at revenue
but I don't love the CFO work of
maximizing profit if you're deciding
that like in the next two or three years
you're gonna go I highly recommend
bringing you a strong financial partner
whether CFO or a controller right
because you know a lot of us and I'm
making assumptions because it feels very
entrepreneurial in here we're good at
the selling part but the maximizing the
profit or what expansion looks like a
lot of us entrepreneurs get caught when
we start getting to that next level and
if you know you're gonna sell they're
gonna look very hard at those financials
so you want to start prepping yourself
you got it
Mike thanks brother yeah yes yeah yeah
so so this is something funny that you
know iris and my team on the creative
side probably talked about behind my
back which is this just unlimited stream
of content that I'm able to come up with
to be very frank guys I mean this I just
think I have a lot to say like and and
not because I love hearing myself talk
which I do it's just that it's just that
I like I'm really gonna end up being
known as somebody who's really good I
think I'm grossly underrated for all the
fandom I already have I really can feel
it as I'm starting to audit myself
against the a players of society I think
I got lucky that my mom and dad had sex
at the right moment you know I mean it
it's it's DNA right it just kinda seemed
that so many of you whether you can sing
or play basketball a rap or draw or be
good at business like this was like
there was a reason I was an anomaly an
enigma when entrepreneurship wasn't cool
like I've always had this thing and so
for me comes very natural first of all I
have 8 to 12 core principles and I'm
very good at synthesizing culture and
making it feel fresh even though it's
the same [ __ ] and the only reason people
here have been following me a long time
is if they
follow me for a long time because if you
follow me for a year you pretty much
figured out what I'm up to the reason
somebody would stay longer is I'm good
at understanding what's happening right
now
you-you-you eventually figure out what
I'm up to whether it's the first day you
ever saw me or how many people here
actually let's this is fun for other
people to say by show pants how many of
you the first time you came across my
stuff actually thought I was a straight
dick face didn't like me
didn't like it raise your hands tell the
truth it doesn't hurt my feelings raise
it raise it right so like to me I know
that that kind of percentage happens but
I think in a year or if you catch four
or five pieces of content right
eventually like wait a minute I didn't
expect like you figure out my gift of
gab makes a lot of people on an initial
insight where my cursing makes people
initially be like this guy's a dick face
right but but my actions win over
overtime because what I'm asking for I
think that for me it's the reason I'm
worth following long-term is I know when
audios popping I know what to do like
I'm pushing some people here to make an
Alexis skill or a briefing for
themselves I'm pushing like hey do this
podcast it's gonna matter for him and so
for me it's been very easy it comes
natural I always recommend for people
that it doesn't to use other people why
do you think almost every podcast that
successful interviews somebody else I'm
like one of the only podcasts that's
straight content to your face every
other podcast is interviewing somebody
because it's hard you know what's a lot
easier asking questions so whether it's
using another person to be a guest or
using a one of the reasons I do call-in
shows is that's an easy way for the
askgaryvee show for the work right
because I can give I just walk into a
scary I'd be like this oh yeah like I'm
doing it right now and the reason I can
do it is I know my craft the reason a
lot of people pay attention to who
doesn't do QA you want to tell a subtle
tell and who doesn't know their [ __ ] pay
attention to who duck's some people just
don't want to do QA that's fine
watch the Ducks QA I've been able to
read people in one sec like the amount
of fakers I know out there
right now because they won't do QA like
contractually and they don't do QA
because they're not real super easy to
memorize something and regurgitate it
it's called an actor so using other
people you know what else is good using
other people at the most macro so what
step one another person interview easy
step two Q&A if you know your craft easy
step three something I've seen nobody do
that I would love to do I'm just too
busy social commentary I love the idea
of taking your iPhone going to Times
Square looking at everybody sneakers and
talking about sneaker culture and who's
wearing what or going to a Whole Foods
and looking at packages and pricing like
auditing culture it's cool right I mean
I do it all the time as a person but so
much of what I know like I knew slide
was coming for eight-year-old girls
because I was like watching culture
right like I love watching culture if
you're good enough if you've always had
intuition you know people love
discovering new bands and then they hold
on to and then when the band gets
popular they get mad at them because
they sold out you know look if you've
got that skill try to synthesize that
that would be an super fascinating thing
to watch or listen to I wish I did a
show where I told you what was actually
going through my head when I come in to
like the airport like do you know why I
like flying so much that you're watching
the people at the airport how I got a
snapchat so early I just kept watching
like teenagers opening this yellow app
like five years ago is like what is that
and one of the apps are finally it
popped up in the charts like number 130
I'm like that's the yellow thing you
know I've stopped looking at teenagers
as much because some of the dads were
getting mad at me but like literally I
was like hovering over like like teenage
girls will tell you the future every
time it's just it's a lot easier for
some of the women in here to do it like
creepy 40 year old dudes looking at
young I think enough kids is kind of
weird so but I watch people that would
be a cool show as a third one yes sir
Mike yes sir
as a disrupter what's coming technical
thing like when those many questions
going to be what do you think about
cryptocurrency good material
- like yep as a trending let's let's
talk about blockchain cuz it's Blanco
cuz it's blockchain right I mean you've
got a theory I'm underneath that you got
Bitcoin after that right so I invested
in Bitcoin and a theorem in 2014 right
so and I haven't sold any so I've done
okay right but the reason I don't talk
about it
a lot to put of people that follow me
the most is I don't like talking about
[ __ ] I don't know
right and so it's funny I talk really by
peacock right when I roll when I'm
talking about what I know and I'm real
passive I know a lot about crypt I spend
a lot of time looking at it not enough
to put myself out there because I feel
like I'd really want to like be right
here's the thing with blockchain
blockchain if you play the chess moves
all the way out is the decentralization
of our entire society like if you really
play it out it seems like you're right
you've been into it for a little while
bro this is heavy [ __ ] this isn't
Bitcoin this isn't like hahaha this is
America's not going to let it happen
like as it undermines America itself
like there's a REIT like China is a
funny country I think we have America
propaganda if you look at China the mix
between dictatorship communism and
capitalism China as a country is run
much more like the way we run our
businesses it's a little capitalism
that's a little bit right so China
making it illegal is the preview not an
anomaly we as Americans like a [ __ ]
China right
communism right China is advanced so
here's I think about it look the amount
of money being made on icos right now
fast quick bucks is no different than
Bebo selling for 850 million dollars
stay oh well there's some people gonna
make some real money in this period
I love it I think it's batshit
interesting about you and I me buying
your home and transacting the lease on
the blockchain right [ __ ] the bank [ __ ]
everybody look great I'm a big buyer in
my altruistic nature as a human if you
think America is gonna let it happen at
the level of that extreme it has no
vested interest no government has vested
interest in this collapsing them but if
you play it out outside of military this
is what holds it all together
currency it's big man it's real big it's
really hard for me to really play out
everything other than the following it
is so disruptive that it's very
difficult for me to see the governments
of our society going down without a
fight
yeah and the windows already we're
living the window do you know you've
seen the famous story of the guy who
bought a pizza with like 10,000 bitcoins
bought a pizza for like 50 million
dollars like we're living in it we're in
it right now there's a lot of people
making a lot of money these icos there's
so many rackets being run right now and
so they'll have their window but it's
fascinating technology right it's like
the most destructive thing that's since
the internet that I can't even wrap my
head around super gnarly [ __ ] you got it
I bought more Google ads so like the
biggest thesis of me right now for the
people that follow me the most is I day
trade attention right what I think I'm
better at you know to the point of me
putting out more content consistently
than anybody it's because I believe that
social networks have a disproportion
amount of attention and people don't
realize it I just don't understand how
people don't realize it like it's what
we spend all our time on like not 14
year olds 30 year olds and 40 year olds
and 50 year olds and 60 year olds like
there's the social media celebrities
whether in business or kids are way more
famous than the actual celebrities it's
not even close I think people are now
saying wait a minute these people are
kind of famous too
none of them there's no mainstream
celebrity as famous as any of the top
100 social so
including Cardassians were as much
social as they are mainstream in
whatever right so I built my dad's
liquor store on the back of email and
Google AdWords but I didn't spend enough
on Google Adwords when I talk about my
dad's business Krung from four to 60
million every time I hear it in an intro
and an interview I say it should have
been four to 250 it could have been much
bigger if I was smart enough to you know
I'm not a poker player but what I had at
the time by owning all the wine terms on
Google for five and ten cents that
clicked before anybody knew what it was
was I had the best hand
and I wasn't going all-in and that's why
I'm so passionate for all of you to get
more serious about social right now
Facebook Ads
is that moment and in ceramic Lancers is
that moment and I would say everybody in
here is under spending their mental time
and their money on Facebook and
Instagram much to the demise of their
upside you could still win direct mail
still works radio still works Google
still works things still work just not
as good I love when people like Gary
great great but I'm [ __ ] I went from
0 to 4 million this year my business I'm
like what's wrong with 9 [ __ ] so this
is about upside so really to be honest
with you that you know like because most
things I don't look back I think looking
back is insane I think you should learn
but I don't I'm not good at even
remembering what the [ __ ] happened last
year let alone in my 20s because it
doesn't matter other than the learnings
that I feel in my body that helped me
navigate so I don't like to dwell or
things of that nature but to answer it
so it brings back you know the reason I
answered that was so that I can go on my
rant for you on Facebook and Instagram
right now because I want you guys to be
compelled to get way more serious how
many people here which yeah amber amber
do you know many people in here have run
a little bit of facebook ads with one
creative variable and it didn't work and
they beamed Facebook is not working
this room too so I'm interested in
putting pressure on that conversation
because you will benefit because it's
underpriced attention how much you will
pay to target people within a 5-mile
radius of your shop or people that are
interested in your product is
underpriced i just don't know what else
to say if it costs you three dollars to
get in front of them it should be 11 and
you're paying 11 somewhere else that
it's worth 2 that's all now the tough
part is you have to make a picture of
video that makes them do something
Google was so great for everybody
because it was an intent based marketing
I am looking for a karate studio I am
looking for red wine where can i buy
bananas that was easy you just put it in
front of them the creative part didn't
matter it was all blue letters that's
why everybody liked it so much we're
back to more like TV and print it's
harder you're welcome who's got the
green bag awesome a man what's up what
is Bryce other people's opinions by
telling your mom to go [ __ ] themselves
Bryce I'm so hot on this man I am so sad
that the reason you get a reaction like
that is a mix between it's funny to use
the word mom and [ __ ] in the same
sentence right but but it's way more
true if you listen to the tone of the
laughs in there and saw what I just saw
the truth in what I just said is so
powerful I am so sorry
first I am driven by gratitude you want
to know when everybody
I just how many of you saw me on the hot
ones the hot wing kind of thing some of
you saw this so that was a huge that's a
huge audience and a lot of people who
didn't know me and every time I do Joe
Rogan or hot winds or a TV show where I
where a lot of people don't know who I
am I know I'm in for it because 20
percent of the crowds gonna hate me
right
but what's fun about YouTube shows as
the comments are there so it's been four
hours the other day and they're engaging
with the people that said I was terrible
but a lot of people spoke what one word
and they used two different words just
in the comments one word I would say 50
people wrote in one word of that episode
cocaine and about another hundred wrote
adderall and I replied to every one of
them all of them especially as somebody
whose mom brainwashed them to never even
try smoking a cigarette right I replied
gratitude I have so much energy cuz I'm
grateful not only am i grateful for the
talent I was naturally given the
ridiculous parents I was given and the
incredible advantage of being an
immigrant I'm grateful that my parents
were so awesome they never made me feel
inferior right and so many of you
whether through a sibling or a parent
had a miserable sad negative parent who
tried to impose their negativity on you
and misery loves company and its
greatest execution as parents on kids
there's something we never talk about
it's not talked about enough and so if
my legacy when I die when I take my last
breath if you asked me what I really
think I'm gonna think I think I'm gonna
think that I was the human being that
came along and brought the most
awareness to this kind
recession it is my absolute passion
because I've seen what my grandma did to
my dad and I know what my mom did to me
and it's a big [ __ ] difference bro
it's called happiness so why do I think
a lot of you don't do [ __ ] because
you've a you other people's opinions of
you why do I think you have that because
you weren't given self esteem as a kid
and you were gone the other way and if
there's anything one of the biggest
reasons I act like a big-shot is because
I want kids to become fans of me so that
I can then become the shield for them to
have confidence to do good things not
bad things because if I'm cool then
they're not talking about Ferraris and
[ __ ] gold watches they're talking
about hardwork humility empathy and
kindness
so I'm in the best price and the best
part of my career because snapchat and
Instagram and YouTube have allowed me to
get way down the funnel I'm getting to
15 year old dudes and 15 year old dudes
can go either way real quick and the
fact that I'm gonna get them all to come
to me to become better men that's [ __ ]
Legacy bro so through a long-winded
eight years have finally figured out
it's that man you guys worry about what
other people think I brought up the
celebrity thing with Instagram right you
just care what other people think and I
don't I care what people think when they
know who I am
but there's people in here who've
literally not done something because
they don't like when somebody leaves an
anonymous comment on a picture that says
they are ugly or suck and the thought of
that breaks my heart
I get pumped when people say I suck I've
only if you follow me carefully
only in last three months because I just
want to help I'll tell you why I'm doing
it only the last three months have I
even really gotten a little more
detailed about Wine Library and the fact
that I own nothing of it and I'd built
that business for my dad mainly it's
because other kids who are looking up to
me have other friends that tell them you
can't look up to that guy his dad gave
him a liquor store he sucks so I wanted
to kill that excuse because I don't want
these kids to go down the [ __ ] path got
it
like people think I got something handed
I had it the reverse I gave up the first
13 years of my life to build my dad's
business for him and left with nothing
because I wanted to pay him and my mom
back you know so that's where I'm at
[Applause]
Wow how are you good bro so thank you
for coming out it really means a lot to
a lot of people more than just me and
you started about a leadership with his
team now you are traveling going out
doing all these things so you probably
don't spend hours correct with your team
that's right running your company it's
right how do you make them feel less
like they're listening I follow every
one of my employees unsocial so I see a
lot of what is going on in their lives
the reason I over spend on a huge HR
team is there gathering info and through
FaceTime and texting and emojis and
emails I can get a lot done and through
osmosis let me tell you how life
actually works when you're nice to Karen
and you did something right Karen tells
Susan in the girls bathroom the truth
Susan then thinks you're a good person
guys reputation matters look what do you
think is going on in life when you
consistently do the right thing bro you
get the halo effect you don't need to
see everybody brand so many people in
the transactional business
what's my customer acquisition cost what
was my conversion what's my lifetime
value cool if you want to build
something it works it just doesn't work
as big as what I'm up to Brant
so I scale by scaling the unscalable
which is I don't judge myself and I do
the best I can I get to as many people
as possible I consistently do the right
thing by the judge in the jury of the
Lord looking down on it and I let the
osmosis in the back room chatter scale
it and then when I don't like it and I
don't think it's working
I force them to come and see me one by
one for 50 minutes two times a year you
know what I mean like like it worked for
me you have to remember how many people
here our parents that have children that
are over the age of 10 whether they're
10 or 40 great we parented art you know
I'm at 8 and 5 but the way my life kind
of played out my loner brothers Alette
years younger I had businesses at 22 I
think I was really built to be a dad
long before I was a dad you don't parent
your child at three the same way you
parent them at eleven the way you parent
them at eighteen the way you parent them
at thirty it worked for me and now I'm
changing it you have to work for them
and so you have to keep the pulse on so
I all but all the above you know maybe
in the next two years will be fifteen
minutes and maybe I'll do so much damage
aka good that maybe I can go back to
three years of osmosis I don't judge
I just awed it and day-trade the moment
you know what got us all into this room
today has nothing to do with what's
gonna get us to the next level and way
too many people hold on to what got them
here because they've got one move you
know and I think if you've got you know
back to fighting and back I'm a big
boxing fan like if you've got one punch
you could do some damage for a long time
I got right but once there's enough film
on you you'll be exposed so I'm trying
to keep mixing it up man right
look over here yes that's right I'm
actually this is actually the first day
I'm wearing um I don't know if you guys
know this type of sneaker coming out I
figured if an athlete sand rappers can
do it why can't entrepreneurs so this is
it this is the first day I'm wearing
them this comes out uh November 14th I'm
pretty pumped you know what I love doing
I love doing things that are no lose
situation so if this works like works
well then that was the first
entrepreneur what a signature sneaker
and it's really cool in my byline right
and if it doesn't my buddies get to make
fun of me for the next 30 years and say
remember when you thought you were so
[ __ ] cool you can have a sneaker you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
no lose situation oh man
Oh who's got the we are we doing that
next yes good very ready Robert Robert
you're fine thanks brother so we've
started a good for you have you made it
a watch show yet Facebook watch this new
TV thing they're doing okay so you've
been putting it on your fan page like I
was doing go Google Facebook watch read
an hour's worth of by the way this is
what pisses me off please don't ask me
like how to do something tactical I love
when people like you know my comments
like Gary Vee like okay enough with the
[ __ ] crush it and rah rah give me
some tactical [ __ ] right like you suck
give me tactical [ __ ] I'm like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
tactical [ __ ] should be done on Google
and YouTube either you can read or you
can watch depending on how you learn
there's nothing you need from a human
it's all on the [ __ ] internet for
free right like this like like
everyone's like give me something
tactical like oh you mean like when I
put out content about snapchat for six
months and then all these [ __ ] watch
it all and package it up into a $397 how
to win on snapchat ebook that makes you
feel better rekt you [ __ ] idiot
sorry go ahead anyway Google that
Facebook watch learn everything about it
they're trying to push their original
shows how many people here have hit the
video tab at the bottom of their
Facebook and now watch the show on there
so they've picked shows like they pay
for it but then anybody can make a show
here's why you always want to do what a
new platform launches as a new product
when Instagram launches stories or
stickers or Facebook watch or Twitter
does something be smart when platforms
have a new feature they vig it so right
now if you have a show on facebook watch
that you started' they're putting it
into more people's streams because they
want to get facebook watch to work so
you're riding the wave of Facebook and
getting the benefit of people who don't
know who you are
got it keep going
that's a mistake okay it sounds about
right
no listen everybody does my niece's I
get it go ahead good good
so a couple things first and foremost
for all of you the whole girls or nieces
or nephews or Rick the 13 year old like
outsourcing to youth in social media is
insane let me explain why out sourcing
to youth that knows what they're doing
for business is smart just the notion
that somebody's a teen and they get it
is insane you're running a business not
trying to hook up Friday night so like
great they can slide into the DM but can
they drive your business right so first
and foremost it is no longer an excuse
to not know about Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube like if you how many
people here own their business raise
your hands you need to know what this
stuff is are you telling me in 2018 that
you don't have 40 hours this year to
allocate into reading or listening or
watching how to become a practitioner in
social media this is the lifeline of
your business right now whether you
understand it an hour you'll understand
it later everybody wants to be a
headline reader or outsource because
they have more important [ __ ] to do the
most important thing for everybody in
this room is to understand how to
communicate with customers and that's on
Instagram and Facebook and LinkedIn and
on and on so I implore you number one
for you to get educated because you have
no idea if those two girls are hosing
you or not right and then the other
thing is business people need to get
smart so many people care about how many
followers and likes they have you're not
paying your mortgage with how many likes
you get on Instagram but it's back to
Jab Jab Jab right hook it's also not
nobody's following you on Instagram if
every [ __ ] post is liked by my plan
sign up for my course come to my studio
give me your money give me your money so
the place to start is mental the place
to start is using this moment that we
have together
and say [ __ ] it I need to get smart
because this is like balancing my
checkbook it was like paying my taxes
it's just real way more real than people
think and let me tell you why
forget about all these social networks
the next thing voice a RvR or something
I don't know yet it's gonna be the same
principle as this the reason I'm so good
at social is because I cut my teeth on
Google and email and then didn't hold
romantic to it and became even better at
the next thing got it
so you guys are running a marathon in
life and so I want to get you on the
treadmill on social now because it's
gonna be a proxy to the next thing you
have to do how many people you're
retiring in the next ten years and I
don't mean that you're gonna crush it
sell your business and buy an island I
mean you're old and you're [ __ ]
finished - respect for the rest of you
for the rest of you what do you think
has happened in the last ten years let
me remind you basically everything that
we live on now
smartphones social networks but
everything's what the hell do you think
is coming in the next ten years and if
you're outsourcing social now you know
prayer in understanding crypto or AR or
VR or everything that's coming next you
need to get on it now
don't you love you know back to training
I love the fighting analogy stuff I
can't I'm just such a big fan of it
because it has such proxies I love the
one my friend or it's like doing
business in China or Russia the naivete
of an American going doing business in
China is so funny to me they think it's
the same rules right or when you get a
tough guy into mixed martial arts
because they were good at boxing they're
like it's a different sport man like so
we know it in our things but then in
business we do the same [ __ ] we make fun
of people who don't work out
consistently and think like a pill or a
drug is gonna do it you got to do the
right things gonna eat right you got a
but done in business those say like all
of the muscle heads on Instagram that
the Emme make me laugh so much they say
discipline in the gym and the way they
eat but in business they're looking for
the shortcut which is exactly they make
fun of in Fitness
right like all my all my [ __ ] buffed
out buddies are like no no but Gary
what's the [ __ ] in I'm like dude there
is no steroids in [ __ ] business you
know like it is what it is my man
thank you brother I can tell thank you
for the love it's awesome yes BB media
company yes dude you have it better so
I've done much better with my BB
investments than might be to see
investments in helping them on social
media
you literally know the names of the
people you're trying to reach I mean
that's insane you know awesome that is
veiners have been a gift compared to
Wine Library anybody potentially could
have been interested in buying wine beer
liquor mate or media is super simple
like on you the CMO of craft and Proctor
and you know Toyota and Pepsi so I would
make content on Instagram excuse me on
LinkedIn and Facebook with ad dollars
targeting employees of the organizations
that you're trying to get to guys how
many people b2b in here so just for a
couple of you great hire hands I just
want to get a sense don't be scared okay
so to me there's a if back to the last
question right being a practitioner when
you run a Facebook ad you can run
against anything it's how many people
here have spent $100,000 on Facebook and
they were the people that clicked the
buttons that made the creative raise
your hand right - this is huge this is
huge this is a huge opportunity when you
become a practitioner of Facebook Ads
you'll [ __ ] your pants of how good it is
it's incredible
you can run ads against employees of
give me a company that you'd love to use
your your b2b product give me one
what's that yours good you could
literally make a video that targets
their employees on Facebook and
literally the creative the writing or
the video says does your CEO know and
then you could literally forward it to
them like you could literally target him
on LinkedIn it's incredible you know the
names so but you have to make the
creative smart so a lot of people need
to be the CIO or CTO or CFO is the
person making the decision and people
say to me they're not on Facebook I'm
like I get it so run ads against
employees of the company and the title
of the video is does your CFO know then
the CFO gets 13 emails and she's like
what the hell is this she watches it and
then she contacts you it happens every
day
b2b is incredible at social yes great go
to Instagram and Twitter where there
half-assing it and DM them since they
never get any DMS they'll be there cool
I got a DM and instead of saying buy my
[ __ ] bring them some value learn listen
always listen figure out what they're
struggling with and give them a make an
e-book or app or a PowerPoint or a video
for free that takes you some time and
money and then DM them and say hey
number one thing I've noticed in the in
the mixed martial arts world is that
Studios aren't doing the following and
its title 11 things you should be doing
it'll be three minutes and 19 seconds
you'll give them value and one in every
three of them will look deeper into you
and give you business we have to start
with value you know it's funny women
entrepreneurs are always more intuitive
to my style of marketing because they've
been the ones hit on and you know like
soul - right
so they intuitively understand they
respond more when there's value brought
up front you know and so there's a very
small and smart cadence of hunting and
farming bringing value we need to
romance our customers a little bit more
value it always wins
we're sold to all the time right we're
pounded like you know what everybody's
LinkedIn strategy is bulk spam email
just gonna email everybody and tell like
I know that some of it works it just it
works a hell of a lot better if you
bring some value next thank you okay yes
yes yes so couple things first and
foremost when you're an owner of the NFL
you have to worry about the other 31
owners so the way I would handle it is
first get a pulse of what my other 31
business partners thought as far as
kneeling as somebody you know this is
where Americans are oftentimes confused
from a kid that was born in the Soviet
Union the thought of not allowing people
to express themselves in any shape or
form including if it really hurt your
feelings is something that I'm just not
willing to go down that path so if we're
gonna respect our amendments if we're
gonna respect number two with the right
to bear arms we're gonna respect number
one with freedom of speech and so it
would not bother me if a player kneeled
during the national anthem I'm awfully
aware that that breaks people's hearts
it makes them mad at me for that stance
I just it's just how I feel about it
because I think most of the people
making comments about it have never
lived in a communist country and know
what it tastes like to not add the
option
[Applause]
they're not overpaid athletes they're
not overpaid athletes no no I listen I
understand the stance and by the way the
great thing about our country is I'm
deeply empathetic and respect the living
[ __ ] out of somebody's opinion the other
way I would just remind people they're
definitely not overpaid because they're
paid based on the reality of what the
market conditions created we allowed
them to be paid this way because we
drive the revenue if everybody wants to
stop watching football and drive that
down they're more than welcome to I just
you know I've had a lot of fun with a
lot of my friends who take the other
stance they don't like pro football but
when their homies at Alabama and LSU and
Texas start kneeling they like their
Longhorns they care about their Bama
boys so it's been really interesting to
watch I have a lot of empathy um
and I'm super in tune with it because of
the Communists you know you know freedom
of speech kind of thing it's so deep in
my you know both my grandfather's spent
ten years in jail in Russia because they
were Jewish so you know I also really
you know I also have the benefit of
having six of my eight core friends in
college be African Americans which led
to me going to the mall you know the
first four times in college and getting
pulled over three times like the big
thing that we're missing in our country
are now is the empathy we're not putting
ourselves in other people's shoes and
we're letting everything get pull it off
sized like are we gonna make everything
a political issue because basically
we're in a emotional Civil War right now
which is cool I'm fine with it every
Empire should fall you're welcome
hey brother Eric goes use a lot of
analogies and wearing tons of martial
artists and lawyers yeah and you know
fair sports haven't seen him signing and
mixed martial artists don't want to help
you guys with the UFC yeah what what do
you think is the future of mixed martial
arts or the industry or
opportunistically yeah listen fighting
is as old as they're you know like it is
cord I mean it might have been it
probably was the first sport right if
you really if I had a bet on it
it was the first sport maybe maybe
racing you know I'm trying to think
about like how it went down but
nonetheless Vayner sports is only
football right now
the next two sports that will expand
into based on mine and AJ's interest are
most likely eSports and the NBA we
haven't really thought about going into
reppin Talent in the UFC and mixed
martial arts I'm extremely bullish on it
I think it's an extremely lucrative
category and territory and so we haven't
thought about expanding it their necks
because we've got a little bit of a road
map but it's something that if that if
you know AJ's really running Vayner
sports and I'm like creating the halo
effect and so I'll have to react to like
where he sees some of the opportunities
as well so that's kind of a wrap but
like a yeah please please make a
fraction in revenue as much wanna be
made with Annamayya
you know any NBA or NFL or anything else
yeah I mean I think that can change
right like to me i yeah I never make
decisions based on like what it is now
it's more about my anticipation to your
point it'll be interesting to see how it
evolves and it's a super look I think
fighting you know in whatever form is
always quite lucrative because it's so
primal to us the thought of like the big
event were two people you know like
fight is so 100% always going to be
there for us we just have a lot of
interest in the NBA and the esports
thing is super interesting to me like to
me if if Boehner Sports was here 12
years ago I would have done UFC to me I
want to catch something like in a
different part of the you know MBA and
NFL's interest graph esports / UFC on
the base of the maturity of the market
the less mature something is the more
opportunity there is and so for me I
want to be looking at that yeah second
yes so we came with the mindset of
working super bar
[Music]
so worthless it's work hard and you find
men end up being just trapped that even
when you succeed and you know like
thanks for the timber a lot of my school
grew by four hundred percent over two
years so that's what I mean yes
so now when everything goes so much
better I end up not being able to stop
myself from work you can wonder the fear
of just family surfers yeah it was a
feeling under the conflict of the whole
family and mindset of my only family
because now anything different and I
know I can be happy I know I need to be
grateful and I know I can succeed but
most people don't think this way because
always I'm aware so I mean look there's
a lot there you can stay here so we can
go back and forth stay at the mic so I
think look first of all the back half of
your question was the whole point that I
made earlier which is if you could go
inside my brain and my feelings and my
DNA right now it would either scare you
or confuse you how much I do not allow
my wife children or parents to factor
into the way I think about things at the
same token their opinions of me or my
life you have to find the calibration of
respecting people's opinions but not
allowing them to dictate your actions
because you're gonna go down the path of
becoming bitter with them at the end too
many of us protect our family and pander
to them because we want it to be good
without realising how it plays out at
the end which is in our older years we
have a lot of resentment towards them
because we think we allowed them to
dictate our behavior but that's not true
so you know listen we share a lot of
common themes I understand
first of all on the working part first
you have to ask yourself if you do you
want to work less I'm asking yes well
then work less
you know what I mean like the way you've
got to think about it is whatever
management you put in or whatever
happens first you have to immediately
think it's gonna do less second you
can't hold your managers accountable one
thing I know about Eastern European
employers is when they do moves like
that they expect those people to work
like a horse the way they did it's not
their business unless you're willing to
give your manager the same amount of
money and a piece of the business
why should he or she work as hard as you
so first you have to deploy practicality
reality and everything my friend has a
price everything so if you want to work
less and take a spa treatment and go
fishing and pick up basketball and learn
how to sing or whatever the [ __ ] you
want well know that it comes at the
expense of your business growing and
that's okay you know and once you learn
how to stop thinking about the judgment
of others on your behavior everything
opens up easy to say but it takes a lot
of practice and it starts with the
reason I would say [ __ ] you mom [ __ ] you
dad it starts with practice if you sit
down your family be like I'm doing this
I know exactly what you're thinking it's
my life I'm sorry if it hurts your
feelings this is what I'm doing cuz I
don't want to resent the way I do it is
tell the truth
I don't want to resent you later and I'm
gonna bring you I always tell people
whenever I've had to had that talk with
my dad or mom or brother I always tell
people I'm gonna break and if I break
then it's all broken and I promise you
when you put them into a corner instead
of them putting you into a corner it
gets real funny I'm fascinated by
bullying in general and families bully
the moneymaker and their family and a
funny thing happens when you go and
treat them like a bully they fold like a
cheap chair because they have no [ __ ]
leverage you like that right hits home
right when you're the money maker
everybody gets real used to you when you
flip it on them they've got no move
let them go make money you're welcome
it's only it's a real thing like it's
hard for a lot of us if we're the driver
people get into a cadence and we as
somebody like when you know how to make
money you start taking on almost this
responsibility you start helping you
love your family I love everybody I
[ __ ] love you guys I don't even
[ __ ] know you you know like like you
start getting to that place and then
everybody gets into their position I'm
okay with it you're okay with it we'll
get to you in a second like people you
could be okay with it you can be okay
with eating [ __ ] your whole life I've
gone I mean more [ __ ] than anybody I've
ever seen the problem is no no problem
the problem is once you're at a place
where you don't want to do it anymore
you act see what their move is to that
it just practiced one time look I'm not
when you're drunk
not when it's so crazy that you can't
deal with it anymore a month a year
before you break and go crazy and yell
at them at the top of your lungs calm
nice dinner and be like here's the score
it's incredible I've given this advice a
lot it's been game-changing for people's
lives when they've acted on it most
don't act on it cuz it's hard I'm not I
don't think what I just said is easy
it's super hard and the longer it's been
real the harder it is right hey Kelly
very nice sorry
so as you've mentioned just work this
isn't a media business first edition
obviously I love kickboxing if over 250
locations opened another 800 to open
soon credible it does become difficult
in lots of different levels of
competency when it comes to our
franchisees some of them don't even have
a Facebook yes sir so as we grow and as
we expand is it more important for us to
control the content of our brand because
it does take away the intimacy the
personal touch for each market but also
yeah so we've we you know vaynermedia
works with
you know a real estate group that we're
about to announce we just wanted to
announce in 30 days this is a super
tough question my answer is that you do
both and let me explain what I mean by
that I think that you guys should be
overly aggressive on a national scale in
your areas as an an advertiser and
whether it's co-op dollars or you do it
you guys decide and I think you spent a
lot of time on teaching and giving best
practices to your franchisees creating
ways to communicate them one of them I
have a really good idea I think you guys
should start an internal b2b podcast an
internal b2b podcast for your
franchisees around best practices
correct or whatever you deem is most
important management style how to treat
employees whatever your religious
pillars are because one more time how
many people listen to my audio the
reason there's so many more hands by
average is because you guys are busy and
audio is a good thing
lottie's franchisees are busy so let
them listen even if they live six
minutes from their location let them
hear you for 12 hours a day 12 minutes
excuse me a day right it's I would
advertise on top of them and then I
would spend a lot of time I think of it
as high low I think most people in the
middle they're kind of doing it as a
corporation they're kind of servicing
their people they give them a tool kit
or something that they never open they
do it one time a year event and bring up
the person that does social media the
best thing give them a trophy and think
it's gonna inspire no internal podcast
really educate really get them there and
also advertise so that you can point to
and say look how good this piece of
content did email them all
yeah yeah so to me it's synthesizing
what's working and send out you know
again I don't think they read email I
don't think they like but listening and
so maybe like maybe in your 30 minute 15
minute you know again interview people
you have a lot of relationships like you
could really crush that you get really
fancy people on your popular do you have
advantage with him and his relationships
I think I'm very very big on audio very
big it's big like if I was creating
vaynermedia today I would be called
Vayner voice if I started today I would
call Vayner voice I would deeply
position myself in Alexa Google and you
know all that building apps for that
world just like iPhone apps in 2007 and
I would be very big on being the
infrastructure for companies around
their internal podcasts we just built I
mean
I'm putting my money where my mouth is I
just renovated for two million dollars a
40,000 square foot 50,000 square foot
studio in Long Island City to do video
and audio production so I believe it it
tremendously you're welcome this is one
more okay this last one nobody picks
okay yes yes
that's a great question I think both can
work lad but you know I think first of
all if you're an introvert and you want
your privacy and you don't like it you
should never force yourself there's
plenty of humongous companies where you
don't know the founder I was getting
worried that people like I like it I
like the admiration I like the
interaction I like all of it so to me
the first and foremost is you realize
either way can work I will say if you
like it and you're a good person and you
don't take down the company with your
off-the-field activities it's it's a
great way to go and that's why I'm very
comfortable with it yes yeah you mean
like Facebook slash Wine Library and
Facebook slash Gary B yes content for
the context once and Wahb something was
super important I'd post on both but a
business talking and a human talking
should be putting out different stuff
people use social media as distribution
not as a place to narrow make native
content they think of social as email
I'll take something and I'll post it on
all my accounts they don't take into a
fact the psychology do you know the
difference between a 40 year old woman
with two kids when she's on Pinterest
and on Facebook totally different her
psychology her psychology when she's on
Facebook is to keep up with her friends
and news on Pinterest that's aspiration
to shop or escapism you have to give her
content that fits her psycho state not
just her demographic State got it
think about how you guys use Facebook
Instagram snapchat even right now and I
could see some of you like picking up on
this you're even thinking different like
you're you're in a different one places
Entertainment one places information
LinkedIn you're a different person than
you are on Facebook like your head's in
a different place I've got to feed you
content the subtle things that I do that
people aren't picking up on has a lot
more to do with that why do I make meme
videos on Instagram why do that same
video look different on Facebook why do
I chop up what I choke why
- copy different on the Facebook post
the Twitter post why did I use hashtags
on Instagram but not on face the
subtleties of the craft I have a knack
of making things look easy but this [ __ ]
is real you're welcome black thank you
for having me
[Applause]
[Music]